bobcat Dana welcome to the show oh hey
hey welcome welcome
it's good to see you guys it's uh that's
good thanks wanna see yes that would be
all put happen sometimes you know I'm
sure you could do a show her you're
doing an everything like a [ __ ] out I
want to do it there's plenty times you
don't wanna do it but do you a is there
like do you get to pick who you talk to
or do you Joe oh good we mistakes them
or we'll get there in like right before
the show that day goat did you say yes
did you say yes to him no I don't think
we did yes what are we gonna do
yeah the monosyllabic answer is always
the best yeah how's it going
good people do say that so like when you
talk to radio guys on the road they say
some comics come in in the morning and
they're just there's just one word or
they want to do yeah a bit on the radio
well often like when you're on the road
in the road when you're on the road in
it you know and you're doing tainting
teabag or whatever it's not gonna be in
the room but the listeners think he's
tame taint is a malignant clinical
narcissist or as the entire building
terrified you've never heard of him yeah
he's broadcasting from his basement in
Sanibel Island don't talk and don't say
anything about the color blue yeah it
really sets him off yeah they go tame is
actually a voice that teabag does but
nobody knows it's the same person I got
that one they wanted me I'm like you
want me to pretend there's other people
Minneapolis I had one in Texas where I
was hanging out it was a great show they
were an Austin they're really nice and
they go hey we got some some guys from
Hill Country here with some rattlesnakes
do you want to stick around and I went
but if they're cool I'll stick around
like I'm a watch so I go I go there in
the green room and I open up the green
room and there's like a duck dynasty guy
with a rattlesnake - shoves it in my
face
nothing I'm done for the day he's cool I
was in Battle Creek in the winter and
they got this thing and they go dust and
diamonds here - so screech is inside and
they want me to do the thing outside so
you know they can pay on the the morning
shows now they'll pay so they can
advertise something like the good
morning Battle Creek TV show so they're
advertising this high-pressured it was
so you can wash your car like a car wash
at home and I'm just like well I'm
outside and I'm doing the commercial I
don't know and they cut and they just
cut to us and I just sprayed the woman
and I just and I start screen she's that
laughing when I hit her feet and I just
did like it's one of those moments like
there's really only two roads to go down
yeah the right road in the wrong now
we're gonna be in this situation again
yeah you know I was doing a benefit
years ago with Michael Bolton was the
headliner and I'm like I'm never gonna
have this kind of access to Michael
Bolton again so he's singing weaving his
magic and I just walk out casually and
then I just grab them and I said
dry-humping tackle and I get dragged off
at the cruise so that I get out of that
dorium and then I run around the entire
auditorium and come back in for the
other side of the stage
then you make a mess the kids room like
they had me they're like ma'am I got
tackled we joked Butthead George HW Bush
not dry humped Reagan at the Republicans
behind me I love any scenario that
somebody who's a performer can put
himself in where security is acting like
there's an audience member chopping the
video of David Cross stage-diving Jim
Belushi no obsession a negative
obsession with Jim Belushi I don't think
I'm talking out of school any by the way
Andy Kindler the great Andy Kindler has
the best mind about Jim Belushi
who died made him famous David David
doesn't like it would just go on stage
do these crazy dances but it was it's
that thing is like quite often I'm just
like in a situation I'm going well well
I got it then I'm not gonna have this
opportunity right right
might as well do it yeah I mean we
watched a video of and I don't know what
it was very recently I don't remember
what festival it was but Shaggy 2 dope
from the Insane Clown Posse came out and
tried to dropkick Fred Durst from what
biscuit Holley was performing that
specifically thinks that magnets are
miracles no shaggy is yeah magnets are
the textbook definition of not a miracle
right simple engineering
I added saying Clown Posse in studio and
I asked them I said you know magnets are
not actually magic they're science right
and they actually turned it around on me
and they said well how do they work and
I said I don't know they said with an
magic so I did the gathering of the
Juggalos and that's what I was gonna do
I was gonna go out there you know when a
negatively charged ion and a positive
share the same space they can't be in
the same man drop the mic boom but turns
out I just wanted to get out of there my
life I was like doing my character from
the 80s that I jettison how long into it
did you say I better go back to [ __ ]
the character oh my god I got to the
venue I feel really embarrassed I put
out a shirt I put on I get it family or
something like that yes don't look at me
like this have you been to the gathering
I shot it twice and it was backwoods of
Ohio I don't remember I don't want to do
with Neil deGrasse Tyson so you see you
guys I went it was it wasn't in Illinois
we outside of the Columbus I believe
Columbus with the airport I or Lexie
Kentucky but the time I had no there's
no light there's no security no it's
just a fence with about they say a lot
more but there was about 7,000 piers
there's nothing calming about a clown in
the woods fires and people just beating
each other up it's like Lord of the
Flies like they suddenly pick somebody
like piggy piggy and they just beat up
one of them and it's it really is the
scariest place I've been and I grew up
like in a house with bikers and so what
you're saying is it's a positive clowns
but there's some how insane I played the
year have to deal tequila oh my god oh
yes you got rocks and [ __ ] throwing it
yeah they knocked over outhouses and
toss poo at her yeah it was like an
inverted GG Allin concert yeah there you
go
man she had good success there twice
like I got a shock it was scary to get
there because there's the baggage like
where the [ __ ] am I going and then you
show up and there was an outdoor tent
with hay set up
I just did I came and I did yeah it was
like I was showing on and I did yeah and
that was the thing it's like I I think
they're really appreciated yeah that you
did it and I had a I had a okay set but
it was the before and after getting in
and out right did you get paid in cash
like I got it I believe I did yeah a
plastic garbage bag you went right back
to the character oh and when I was up on
stage at yeah I'm not that I was like my
wife at the time this is gonna be funny
and she's like she tried to dress like
her version of like a boy you like so
here's the thing honey like irony is not
destroyed Juggalo yes did you it was
upchuck the clown you're opening in I
believe he was yeah so when I was there
yeah I think so checks like going you
got nothing to worry about it's it's
family it's like a Dave Matthews concert
and I'm like well [ __ ] you it's not like
a Dave Matthews concert and [ __ ] you for
thinking I've ever been to a day and so
to story
yeah check his dresser on that says I
left my hatchet at home so he's driving
me around in a golf cart there's a golf
cart there and and like and and and and
we're going through the grounds and the
Juggalos are getting out of the way like
we're like you know who are the
millionaire's they're sorry to god
a can of Faygo first of all no first
this guy runs alongside the golf cart
and just punches him right in the face
and an object just hits the gas he goes
I'm here every year they know me I can't
figure because whizzing in at about 50
miles an hour like a baseball pitching
right in their head
[Laughter]
catches clown and we juggle it I guess
the opening of a James Bond knocked him
out with a cannon then I helped him do
this trailer that was a dressing room
kind of thing and we put a finger on his
head for the slaves people don't know
he's actually an incredibly successful
life coach did you put on your Juggalo
t-shirt before that into it or right out
I was on stage and they threw enough
know it's like it was like a like a bit
of a face-off like you know I used
sincere yeah yeah did you because you
know a lot of the Juggalos they're down
with the clown until they're dead in the
ground yeah so they want to know how
down he was down with a clown it was
just like oddly Kamala Harris is
campaign slogan really drag well yeah
what is the overarching thematic theory
of the Juggalos if you don't know family
family yeah you know their family never
good well that's I'm here to get away
from my family I hadn't I done there
they had a show I figure a channel was
always they hosted like these videos or
something's fuse yeah and I did it and I
I had a good relationship with with
those guys so I think that shaggy poopoo
yes chef shags and J they're silly baby
like violent of Chuck Chuck violent
violent meet stinky stinky do you know
violence is normal dude it's so like the
crazy following it so you talk to them
again my backs bother with the fact that
they were I think homies gonna break I
don't know this in fact they were cool I
think help me going in because I had
done the show and I had a relationship
and they've been doing this for 25 years
yeah I mean they actually they classify
which is stupid they classified their
followers as a gang yeah look in the FBI
won't unclassified out which are not
again
two people that right there and there
there there there's uh how do I say this
not to be but there are a lot of it is
like a lot of I don't mean it it's out
this part I make I have no problem in
front of them but this part sounds a
little kind of saying there's a lot of
broken people kind of coming together
family is probably the theme complete
people who want to have the feeling of
family it is like and I you know it's
like a monster is I think that I would
do like a Star Trek convention total
monster convention it's just a different
a different kind of cosplay it you know
it's like you can dress up like a crazy
clown or you can dress up like but the
card the commitment a little bit
everybody there's a socio-economic sort
of self stratification that happens
people are [ __ ] at the Juggalo that
no one's [ __ ] the Juggalos people
fighting intensely shooting outdoors
it's a much I will say this comic-con in
San Diego not to brag sorry ladies taken
and I'm in the hotel and yeah it's a lot
of it's a lot of cosplay a lot of people
and and they're they're not by and large
if it seems that they are not by and
large afraid of sugar or carbohydrates
and massive amounts right there's other
morbidly obese c3po walking around I saw
coming out of the hotel room just and
this is thinking think about what this
means the saddest Hooker ever why would
she leave in my room she was she was in
a lime green you know that it was just
like thank you for the Klingon right
it's a fun time is up
yeah but nobody's nobody's waiting for
the master of ceremonies to drive by
them so they can punch him in the face
there's a porta far away long but it was
nude there and I want to make it as the
quiz oh yeah the jungle that's why my
pepper kissed her she's one of my
favorite porn stars ever she's a redhead
she's [ __ ] phenomenal she goes every
year she wants nothing to do with me
sexually super pretty she's so hot I'm
sorry lose every year to the gathering
of the Juggalos every year this is a
huge fan you guys asked what the theme
is the point of the gathering
horn knows she's studying to be a
cardiologist which is really it's all
about it's all about clown love yeah hey
that's what it's about as clown love
that you're experiencing I hate clowns
but maybe it was a ellos maybe because
of shakes the clown they don't know how
they feel about shakes how long did you
do because when you gotta yeah I do now
I did I do like 15 I mean it was I fell
I did like I did 46 minutes okay because
we're supposed to do 45 and it was like
the end of the sting I had my wife
you've been great it's late that when
you're going on is there outdoors
they're not even being shitty if they
like you they're not they're just tired
they've been drinking all day it's
[ __ ] like you aren't like 12:30 1:00
o'clock oh yeah they kind of hang out
till your family or wolf boo but they're
not yelling but there's no so they were
great but there's a lot of comics show
up and they don't go on they just never
go I'm afraid it's like yeah okay they
show up at the gig and then they still
they don't go on I mean you're there at
that oh I know you gotta go on I felt
like the stage was the safest place I
was yeah was there it was lit yeah
there's like a lot of drugs going around
and literally and there's documentaries
about gathering of the Juggalos which I
love there I mean half the people there
the clown makeup that they've got on is
being done with spray paint yeah they're
like I'm yes they paint to the face they
know like this isn't gonna wash off
right away right and also just toxic
fumes but it's around you know as where
is it Bob you probably know a little bit
about this as where is the is there a
rage in the real clown community as they
say like Neptune the people that really
take clowning seriously about all these
people are idiots the people the serious
clown people like the by the juggler
because they came after you it yes yeah
I'm sure I mean cuz they like the clown
code of ethics and yeah like you're
never supposed to be in your clown
makeup when you're driving in case you
get killed in an accident
molest a child in your clown make noise
coming out of us that one didn't work no
there's a great line you know on a
YouTube Don Rickles YouTube deep dive
and he was roasting Jerry Lewis in like
1968 yeah you know Jerry's a clown and
there's a lot of great clowns Emmett
Kelly that's about it hey how come it
was so long after shakes the clowns that
you went back into filmmaking actually
as a director I didn't I think I
couldn't get a job as a director after
shakes really good I couldn't and I was
trying I was trying to do rock videos
and commercials and everything I could
try and I didn't it wasn't till it was a
long time and then Kimmel Jimmy Kimmel
was uh he was doing the man show and he
asked me to direct it hey that's like 15
years later it was probably or ten or
twelve I can't remember maybe 12 but mm
but Kimmel's mother was a big fan shakes
the clown so yeah I mean the fact that I
got into directing I mean I that's what
I really love doing I love writing and
directing making movies but and shows
and stuff but if it wasn't for Kimmel I
would never that's how I cracked it he
got me on the man show then I did Windy
City heat for him and then I went and
worked on Chappelle a little bit after
that and then before that it's so if it
wasn't for Kimmel I wouldn't be
directing that drive you crazy though
when you get this crack at directing
you're like this is my passion
yeah what I love and then for the next
12 years yeah I couldn't can't do it
yeah I was really depressed what were
you doing I was I was doing stand-up I
was going out like probably about 40
weekends a year oh you know doing
stand-up playing all those clubs and
trying to get work and writing and I was
starting to write and make I was always
writing and making things that I thought
would get made or stuff for other people
and then I finally was like I don't know
if I can even write a script that people
can read and I and I wrote this this
movie it was
it's a kind of a rom-com but with a tiny
bit of bestiality in it it was called
stay and and it was yes so in that movie
I shot for 20 grand and I'm not in it
and then it got into Sundance and that
kind of changed everything but you know
I it was Kimmel let me direct his show
and everything that changed I wouldn't
be a directive or how how long did you
take off from statics I know I didn't
you always kept doing Santa but you took
off for a while right yeah I take it off
and again like now we're out doing dates
Dana and I and I haven't done it like
this in years and it's actually fun like
yeah last night we're at the Bell House
and it's it's just been fun are you
doing it tonight to the Bell House yeah
bellows the Bell House tonight tomorrow
night we're in Boston at the Somerville
theatre and then we go to Washington DC
- the Kennedy Center Annapolis Maryland
in Philadelphia Somerville shot two
specials there that's an awesome road
that theaters do a movie that's great -
shot something there yeah it has I mean
this staff is a little annoying when I
want to sign at the end but the room
itself to perform have you done been
there with a Film Festival comedy its
Somerville which is now totally
gentrified yeah but when I first moved
to Boston I lived in Somerville and it
was like I think I'm having a heart
attack don't be an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you guys know Gavin and Sweeney right of
course that's funny I don't know those
guys I don't think I met I met Steve
Sweeney once but those like the Boston
Legend community it was Dana and I you
know the ding ho and all that and it's
funny it's it's I do target but the
dinkler was like oh there's a violent
place yeah but you also supported
something out that I never the dingo was
a Chinese restaurant with a Western
theme that was a comedy I don't like
people are like doing I remember chili I
won't name who the people were but if
you
like all name people doing coke off of
the you know those pork ribs with the
horn they be doing lines for the ribs
and they'd be serving that to families
its hi sorry so much I I will say this
I've never in my life done cocaine I've
just never I've never done it I have
seen being in Boston comedy in the 80s
more cocaine done than the Eagles roadie
yeah it was just it was it was it was
everybody was shoveling you don't have
any comically do it right we're on you
[ __ ] doing lines and doing your
late-night Friday says this show was
like I mean the club like after hours we
put cardboard over the windows and I
remember cuz I I don't I I don't drink
and stuff and that's been years but I
remember I was 19 years old and it's
9:00 a.m. and I'm doing blow on the bar
at the ding ho and the and that this
I've been you know off of that stuff and
drinking for 38 years 37 years and I'm
38 and so so it happens as though some
19 years old and the door opens and it's
police and it's like backlit you know I
mean hey like enough cops and I'm gackt
out of my mind and I'm sitting there and
I'm like oh I'm going I'm going to jail
and then cops go Lenny how the [ __ ] are
you Letty Clark
when he wears a white hat in this this
here's the story about how insane that
place was was Barry Crimmins who my butt
buddy who I did a documentary on call me
lucky he had broken his fist he had
punched the wall so he's in a cast right
and so I just stopped drinking and this
guy another comic who I'm not gonna name
because I want to save his face but he's
in a blackout and he's got me in a
headlock and he's trying to pour liquor
down my throat and so and so Barry comes
in he's like let him go I come let's say
the guy's name let him go and he goes
the guy goes hug me or hit me mr.
Crimmins and creamy to it but it's also
poetic insane no is that a guy is just I
don't want to get the names wrong but it
was like a heckler is like I'm gonna go
home and get my knife you know and he's
like go get your [ __ ] knife who are
comedian adjacent beat the guy just beat
the [ __ ] out of oh good so he's getting
damn good hey yeah you forgot your name
[Laughter]
this club's got hecklers the move the
move from San Francisco from Boston to
San Francisco the comedy scenes it was
like you learn how to swim in a snake
infested swamp like the hot tub is under
a hundred I hope you're okay yeah yeah
did you live in San Francisco or just I
started in Boston and moved to San
Francisco and then I moved to LA I sort
of followed Bob and literally you moved
to San Francisco because of Robin you go
from Boston which is very I mean it's my
home it's a very working-class place
it's a it's a it's a port town it's
rough-and-tumble to come out of that
comedy scene is like marine boot camp
like you're ready for anything literally
people walking onto the stage during set
drunkest Kenny Rogers and said guys in
the front row [ __ ] a dog threatening
you if you make the dog laugh Cisco and
the people are literally wearing Berets
everybody was literally wearing a
[ __ ] beret
yeah man wooden that wasn't that like
that the San Francisco which I was never
part of that festival that competition
is huge but well there's a huge deal to
win that for the net for the day after
you want it as a history of like people
who didn't win you know oh he did not he
didn't win
Stephen Wright didn't win oh you know
what maybe that's that they maybe say
coming in second is the yeah I don't
know I I came in fifth the year Jake
Johansen won so he was you know he's
good
our friend Dan Spencer he was in it I
remember and it's like it the fixes and
there's no way he's gonna win so he's
just hooked like because I know what do
you how he did it I just there I was the
Edit rig sauce and it just looks like he
pissed his pants
small squirt gun in his pocket and he
just like he had the trigger hooked up
so he didn't have to put his hand in his
pocket and he was like oh how does that
not win you the competition yeah
unfortunately because he did it in again
and because he did it in Sunnyvale which
at the time was a redneck town like you
would go out of San Francisco ten
minutes and you're in Hayward and it's a
it's a [ __ ] kicker town but now those
towns of San Francisco because of the
tech revolution like now those towns are
just full of millionaires
yeah you go you know they talk about a
pallet like Palo Alto was a [ __ ] kicker
town when we lived there and now it's
the capital of the world
you're gonna soar but there's a kind
again it's not a true story but this one
comic who they said pissed his pants on
stage in Vegas and but I don't think I
know Kip but it like hurt his career but
it wasn't a true story he didn't do it
Wow like you everybody had heard I don't
know some [ __ ] rumor that just
wasn't ready for his career I thought I
heard it too but I mean it was like it's
one of those things that like I guess I
knew exactly who you were talking to
yeah I didn't say his names I don't know
him but I know this story was not true
it's like it's like high school again
like oh yeah he pissed his pants you go
four years going you're the kid who
pissed his pants you're like I never but
I can see how you have to have a sex
tape - well that was the thing I think
it was the Paris Hilton thing like
normally a sex tape would demolish you
mhm
and now it's a go that's how she became
famous yeah - Ian - yeah yeah her ear AJ
yeah may I know this comic he if you
drop a deuce during your sex tape that's
where you have to go now have you done
that mess and that's Cory Booker that's
how he announced that's great every day
cuz he's a dad at our school just like
you know three comics that need to make
dental for the yeah it's really natural
and comfortable just funny people
naturally
whatever the questions are there's no
rhyme or reason yeah so have you ever
gotten aquarium gravel in your eye
why funnily yeah
genius that guy he owns that work yes
he's very smart he's very smart
financially yeah he bought would he buy
the Weather Channel or something like
that he bought one of the no he did and
then he made a movie about
Chappaquiddick he made that
Chappaquiddick movie yeah we bought it
yeah why was it in an effort to control
the weather and then just lied he's
changed his name to Byron bar-sinister
Birmingham it's good it's bad there's
locusts and it's a raining blood and
snakes
so coat well you lie in Minnesota can be
undone seasonably sunny weather you
wrote for The Simpsons in starting in 99
right yeah so when you go into a show
like that is there is there more
pressure to go on to that show and start
writing for them when there's all this
foundation laid or is it less pressure
because no it's awful pressure it's
awful pretty I don't think that it says
if you ever seen if you ever seen the
movie Let It Be The Beatles documentary
they bringing Billy Preston to play play
with them right and you can see this
look on Billy Preston okay I'll just
play with you guys
yeah which guy do I take the lead from
it's you know that was a it's a real it
was amazing room of writers and the
first nine months you've just been
trying to figure out the algorithm of
how they work because it's not a
traditional way to write comedy but the
way that the secret of it is that the
joke is the setup to the real joke it's
a kind of a staggered way to write and I
had a weird background because I was
already pretty well established as a
comedian I'd already been on Letterman a
tad albums I'd had specials I was on
Seinfeld and I made this decision midway
through my career I'm gonna write I'm
gonna do this to and diversify and you
have to obliterate your ego because to
me because it was
a lot of guys from Harvard Lampoon and
then I came in like a Juggalo like I was
I was a carnie you know yeah and it took
a while to kind of calibrate how did
they treat you I mean being like yeah
Harvard guys that would do they treat
you differently or no yeah I think I
mean I'm not in a negative way but it
was I was definitely like I did not go
to Harvard and I did not know all their
friends and and they and obviously
specific cases but it was it was sort of
like huh so did you could you feed
yourself in a comedy club is there like
a hat but you pass around there's a bit
of it but but they were great at you
know I worked with people like mike
scully and george meyer who the truly
brilliant people i mean it george meyer
to watch George wire Mayer work was
alarming because he was so funny we had
one time we had a thing it's called a
Rube Goldberg Homer had fallen off a
roof and he hit a one of those things
called like the gutter no the awning and
awning and then hit a flagpole and then
a visible yeah and we couldn't end it we
didn't know how to end it we've written
ourselves into a corner and it's like
seven people staring at the ceiling
trying to end this thing and then
finally George just and we did
everything you know and a lot and then
finally just just George just goes what
if he lands in a dump truck that's
filled with marshmallow fluff and he's
safe and then after he realizes he's
safe a bunch of scorpions come out and
just start stinging come up with how
many years were you at the Simpson seven
Wow so it took nine months before I got
comfortable and then it was pretty
comfortable yeah and then I got a joke
in the script nuns like okay I can
really really take you that long to get
like none no I think but it was it was a
while it was the dumbest joke of all we
were doing and this is why I like work
again this is we were doing a parody of
the prisoner the obscure BBC series from
the late 60s and one of the things in
the prisoner is when you tried to escape
the village they sent balloons after
these giant balloons and they would
absorb you and that's how you died
and they did that on the show and they
said the balloon after homer and he just
pops it and then they cut back to the
guards watching on the security cameras
and the card goes why did we send
balloons as security and we couldn't
come up with anything and finally after
an hour I said shut up that's why did
you have any favorite episodes or
anything that you get to kind of take
the reins on well my my favorite episode
that I wrote was called a goo goo gai
pan where they went to China and adopted
a baby for Marge's sister Selma
based on my experiences going to China
and adopting a child so that I had a
personal love you know a thing to miss
you got to put some of your emotions
into the Simpson yeah yeah and yeah and
that has a really funny we did a we did
a lot of really funny parodies of the
Miyazaki's like spirited away like
really we have dragons
OMERS Homer is flying to China and the
magical dragon flies up next to the
plane and as for his nuts because can I
and magazaria who's brilliant for some
reason the dragon talks like George
Takei the dragon flies up to the plane
he goes I would like it not because I'll
give you one and he goes you're a very
greedy man the other dragons will hear
of this
and then he flies over it needs two
other dragons and they start singing the
met he goes there he goes the man who
broke a dragon's heart
[Laughter]
I wrote this that daughter
yeah she's now a teenager and I show her
in that link Bouvier is a character on
the show
we were watching slipping the channels
and she sees the show and I go
honey that's you sick yeah no that's you
she's based that's your baby picture
animated that Caracara
you she was yeah like Bob's Burgers in
their defense it's a job to manage my
China it was a hard to adopt here did
you want to go to trial
I don't like Americans to know my my
wife at the time had read a book about
the the one-child policy and then the
way it affects women in China so we
thought we would go do that and but it's
it's one of my favorite things in the
world is the law of unintended
consequences and that's why I always
love it when people think they have it
all figured out like this is what's
gonna and it's you've you never have it
figured out ever in China they needed to
curb the population so the state said
you can only have one child in the
culture of China boys are much more
valued than women if you get married you
and your wife go and live and take care
of your parents and your wife's parents
are screwed Wow
they don't because that's basically your
child is your 401k so all these people
that have a son yes yes your son is we
have a daughter you're screwed right so
all of these poor people would have one
they could have one child they would
have a daughter they go let's try again
and they take the daughter to an
orphanage and drop her off I see and or
worse and so then people come in and
adopt those children but what you so
this was done because women in China had
no power now there's one woman for every
eight guys but I have all the power
because there's supply and demand yeah
so it's just the beautiful say oh you
thought you had it all figured out yeah
you wanna yeah yes now it was really
short term thinking that always it's the
same it's a it's you know talk about San
Francisco in San Francisco all these
giant tech companies are buying up all
of this real estate and you know like
there's a Google the Embarcadero in San
Francisco where the punchline was has
just been bought by Google and they're
kicking out the punch line after 35 I
they realized yeah yes they are and
they're making a Google campus because
you can't just have Google now because
you have to have Google
and for restaurants and a gym because
the people who work at Google don't want
to go out into the street because the
street is now full of homeless people
because they've all been displaced
because the rents are so crazy because
all these tech people who have moved in
right and the big problem in San
Francisco now too much human [ __ ] in the
street so this is your billionaires
paradise no it's always you never have
it figured out so there's always a booty
out the pun I did I just didn't apply
here since when they put them out in
those fall I think late summer do they
have a new location I think what I'm
trying to say is as they said in
Godzilla nature finds a balance they're
actually looking at where the old cobbs
was in the cannery I never did your old
work that's hard though there's
something about a location like in
Boston the the old connection was so
good it was a perfect yeah yeah yes it
was square black I mean we have perfect
place to perform and you could change
you move the sign somewhere but it's
it's sometimes in oh it's always the
room you know it's uh I initially went
Dana and I went on the road I just
wanted to call this the the low ceiling
tour it would be nice because the
original tour the original name was the
hilarious Wilburys are they the warp the
W AARP but yeah that was one of the sand
that's one of the things I don't
understand about comedy clubs on the
road I remember Mike you know Mike
Carano mm-hmm Mike Rowe knows he worked
at The Improv for years and he's not a
comedian but he managed a club and he's
in he's a he's a brilliant photographer
em Mike CR c AR ano he's hilarious
he's sincerely hilariously funny guy
this is not a comedian and aurita he
performs he sings long story longer
he was goes to the Irvine improv which
is you know but he was working in and he
would just book what he wanted we're
gonna put a chandelier in here he was
like why it's like these people that own
comedy clubs and want them to make them
like anything but a comedy club you know
we're gonna have a lid over here and
there's gonna be lobster no black box
light on the comedian stick in the
comedian's hand that makes his voice
loud that's what that's supposed to be
but the the narcissism of the no it's
got to be about the club we're gonna
have a movie playing on the side of the
stage there's a LCD menu it's all these
bells and whistles that [ __ ] because you
don't want anything distracting just
nice nice simple yeah
no clubbers while the lighting on the
chandelier was great it's like the show
was good or the food was good and they
yeah they they bless you they lit up ads
on the walls they do that with a talk
shows whenever every time someone starts
a talk show they they they think they're
gonna reinvent the wheel and it turns
out there's a reason why there's a desk
there's a reason why you sit on that
side there's you know like I remember
the early days of Kimmel they had all
this insanity going on behind them is so
distracting yeah everything and he
wasn't wearing a tie right he said no
and then it's like you know I remember
we were talking about it's just like if
you come out and say something that is
outrageous and you're wearing it tie
then it's actually funnier no yes yeah
it's like MTV they used to have these
sets for their award show that actually
looked like they were a pile of garbage
garbage and then when someone comes up
there and curses or says something funny
outrageous it's like well that's what
you do in a pile why do they sit on the
one side why do they sit aside I don't
know but it ends up just working right
it's like I think it's something to do
with and I'm the the people's innate
visual tracking and how they read Oh
your eyes scan from left to right mm-hmm
Israeli talk shows do the same thing I
know and I know in Japan the talk shows
the the desk is on top you guys are both
like big movie guys and everything and I
know both obsessed with Ed Wood oh yeah
when you go and start both of you when
you start writing movies when you start
I'm gonna try to make my own movie like
what made ed wood so special was that he
wasn't trying to make the worst movies
ever turned out he's very sincerely he's
not the worst film maker cuz none of the
homes are fascinating their original
their Europe's you're going Wow so what
you know sometimes the consistency was
not there though sometimes sometimes
Bela Lugosi isn't always Bela Lugosi but
when you're starting to write movies and
you idolize the guy like Ed Wood yeah
how do you stop yourself how do you
determine yourself would ya from me like
oh I'm gonna make this bad like hood I
don't know I I mean I think you know
people might compare me dead with
because I'm sincere but you know it's
like you know stay calm I'm like well
who wouldn't want to see this don't
worry when I shoot a baby in the first
five minutes of a movie I'm like this is
this should be playing every I make
these movies and I'm coming from a
sincere place now now how they're judged
later you know and I just love to that
you go like okay well clearly everybody
mainstream America would want to see a
movie where people are going around on a
murder Street on a murder streak trying
to kill what's popular yeah in
mainstream America now you pointed out
Monday Morning Quarterback so I when we
were doing that I did the world's
greatest at a movie I did with Robin
Williams there's a if you haven't seen
it I don't know i his son dies during
autoerotic asphyxiations and Robin
Wright's a suicide note to cover for it
and then Robin keeps writing as his dead
son to get heat you know yeah it's like
did he write anything out
you know sleep with this woman so he
keeps writing as his dead son so but I
realized that when I made the move and
it sounds like super into porn so that
it Robins character got over the grief
of his son a little too fast so I came
up with seeing while we're making it and
and and in Robins looking at these porn
magazines on a newsstand and it reminds
him of his son and he starts crying I
shot in Seattle and a crisp nirvana it
plays the newsstand guy because I called
him up when I was crying because I came
up with the scene like really like a
night or two before we filmed it we
didn't have permits and Robin's like so
what do we do if the police come and I'm
like run you can't make art in a mansion
so what does that mean I have to sell my
house no you're gonna be staying at a
chained quality hotel you towards Nevada
tell if we've already asked you about
that yeah you were on the road on their
last tour I did yeah because I met Curt
in Ann Arbor Michigan he he was he
interviewed me on a college radio
station he was a fan of my stand-up
which is always weird for people to hear
it's like finding out that Jimi Hendrix
really loved Buddy Hackett and and then
he heard that I was doing dates with
cheap trick and he was like I guess I
get to do shows with me so so I went out
and did I don't even know how many shows
like 13 or 15 or something but yes I did
once your shows I repelled in nude from
the roof of the Oakland Coliseum at
midnight on New Year's I had I love the
fact that like I still wore a hat like
personally I don't mind
they see my gut in my in my penis but
and I had the innumerable wings I'm oh
that's great and I came in and um it was
funny because I was just like I sounded
like I was like I'm tired to cheering
you up you know go get tired of being
scattered you know that was Elvis's
chimp go get Polly short open up and so
so they tell him like you know countdown
to ten and they go it's you know it's
they give him the signal and I'm holding
all my weight from the roof you know on
a cable you know and he looks up I'm
giving him the brown eye for 150 feet
he's like any goes Oakland you wanna you
wanna hear a drum solo
[Laughter]
three two what and I and I shot down
really fast I had rope burns on my ass
and stomach can I land behind him and he
truly didn't see me look at me he's like
Pauly he's funny and he's like no one
gets me you know like he did you are the
thing we he did where he had a Michael
Jackson impersonator go up and accept an
award for him oh that's great and so but
the story was they didn't no one got the
joke and they're like going Kurt Cobain
is traveling with his own Michael
Jackson impersonator what could go wrong
were you holding you like that type of a
singer people just don't think of you as
funny joke yeah he's still a guy but he
I think that was like I remember him
saying to me like teenage angst is paid
off well now I'm bored an old he is
that's funny yes I did a bunch of dates
open inform and something about staged I
remember what was it was it tad was that
the band you remember those guys there
yeah they're really obese so it when
they were state what they would do is
the lead guy would he would he would act
like he's gonna stage dive take it down
up and run to this to the lip of the
stage and the crowd would just like
spread out and because they didn't I get
crushed and then you do it a couple more
times and then like the third or fourth
time he actually go
away from thinking we know this joke and
then crush them so do you think you Nick
Kurt was smiling down from heaven as you
were trying to get off the Juggalos
stage because you know like I would just
I was at a very self-destructive phase
you know and so the first gig I did was
the Aragon Ballroom in Chicago and I
truly wouldn't say this kind of thing I
don't know about you I mean you how
often do you do you ever say something
you go I wouldn't say that now oh when I
look back at all material yeah yeah I
mean there's some times if something
pops up Rahl this from my old CDs I'm
like yeah I would rephrase that and make
it either but did you ever like like
because because when I was in Chicago
and Michael Jordan I retired from
basketball and so I'm on the bus with
the Nirvana's and everybody's got these
handmade signs like Michael come back we
still love you and we don't know it's
not big sports fans
none of us so so we had to have explain
well Michael Jordan so I go out there
and I go hey I feel bad for Michael
Jordan but for 40 million dollars a year
I'd shoot my own dad in the head so yeah
so so in order to get me out of the
venue they had to put a towel over my
head all they hated you for it oh there
was more people back in the behind the
venue to beat me up and then there was
to meet the band so they had this great
bad guy wrestler yeah over my head and
then this huge security guy just lifted
me up my feet never hit the ground and I
just just he he goes just relax your
body the next thing I know I'm in the
back of a van and that was yeah and in
hindsight I wouldn't say moment you just
you look at
yes this all you want to know it I I
truly think the reason I said that was
because it was going well yeah yeah the
show is going okay and then they're
there and I'm like a [ __ ] you owe your
punk rockers your parents dropped you
off in minivans yeah talk all night
you'll never see your Nirvana's just
fighting with 4000 faces when you're up
in the rafters of the Oakland Coliseum
and you're naked yeah except for wings
and you're hanging on to her head in
your mind do you just think there's no
business like you know when I when I
landed I went to look to get my clothes
and someone had taken them as [ __ ] and
there's bombs going off cause it's
midnight in New Year's and so I'm just
standing naked next to him like the
noble warrior is nude and so I learned
this when you're naked at midnight you
don't get a kiss new guy like when you
when I was walking around backstage no
don't make eye contact